[Music]
at first glance far cry 5 is morph the
same open-world gameplay mayhem we've
come to expect but as it turns out
there's a lot of changes both big and
small that makes Far Cry 5 feel fresh
and new so we got a list of tips and
tricks you'll want to know before
jumping into Far Cry 5
[Music]
I know what you thinking no I ain't
gonna have you climbing towers all over
the county for me so don't worry a lot
has changed from the days of climbing
towers and littering the map with dozens
of icons the game takes a much more
natural approach so instead you will
discover everything by simply exploring
so if you decide to head over to that
nearby apple orchard in the distance
chances are there is something waiting
for you the 3d map is detailed enough to
see major landmarks and locations making
it easy enough to mark new areas to
explore your binoculars are a useful
tool in aiding your efforts as you can
use them to place a waypoint onto a
location in the distance similar to
placing beacons or stamps in the Legend
of Zelda breadth of the wild in fact the
way you explore and discover in this
game reminds me a lot of breath of the
wild and I mean that in the best way
possible so as you're traveling keep an
eye out road signs will reveal hunting
spots finding maps will mark a nearby
buildings for you and always always talk
to npcs who will tell you about nearby
missions outposts and prepper stashes
cults drugs are everywhere in the valley
they put it in our water which means
it's getting into our food it all starts
at the green bush fertilizer plant so
explore
far cry 5 is a game that wants you live
in its world in replacement of the
previous games where you'd be crafting
to upgrade inventory or earning XP to
earn skill points all of this is now
combined in the perk system completing
challenges like a certain number of
weapons specific kills or animals hunted
gets you perk points so it's always a
good idea to check up on your challenges
every once in a while if you're looking
for some upgrades so what perks should
you focus on they're all good for
different styles of play but here are
some general purpose ones useful for
everyone on the survivalist tree I would
definitely put points into harvest
master which doubles new rewards from
plants and animals which is great for
making money I'd also invest in all of
the health boost upgrades because this
game is pretty tough and on the base
health you go down real quick the repair
torch is a useful tool that lets you fix
up vehicles but you can also use it to
open up a safe on the renegade tree pick
up the parachute for when you need to
make a quick escape
off a helicopter and the wingsuit for
when you want to enjoy the lovely
Montana countryside both these give you
a lot more options in traversing Hope
County and they're just really fun to
use especially in combination with each
other for the assassin tree get grapples
so you can climb up grapple spots like
in Far Cry 4 and locksmith so you can
open safes and doors without needing a
key for the prepper tree grabbed journey
pack to increase your item inventory
additional holster gets to a third
weapon slot and weapons collector gets
you the fourth weapon slot you'll find
yourself wishing you could hold all
manners of guns so I recommend getting
these as quickly as possible money
doesn't just naturally accumulate as
quickly like a dozen previous Far Cry
games but you can still make a lot of
money if you know what to focus on
hunting and skinning animals is no
longer needed to craft things like a new
wallet so it's mainly meant as a way to
make money as I previously mentioned the
harvest master perk doubles your rewards
from animals so $100 feathers becomes
$200 and a doubled cougar skin Nets you
four hundred and fifty dollars you
should also keep your eye out for safes
inside buildings I mentioned before that
you'll need either the repair torch or
locksmith perk to open them but placing
an explosive on them also does the trick
the last method is the prepper stashes
these are really cool side missions
where you need to do some light
environmental puzzle solving to get
access to a pile of loot whether that's
swimming across the river and shooting
the lock off a door or navigating a barn
full of beehives
you're rewarded with a pile of phat cash
a couple magazines that give you free
perk points and sometimes other goodies
like a new weapon so definitely do the
prepper stashes not only are the rewards
well worth it but they are also some of
the best missions in the whole game
and speaking of missions it seems
Ubisoft has finally learned because Far
Cry 5 ditches their open-world
cookie-cutter formula for the first time
Far Cry has side missions like proper
Rio last side missions with unique
dialogue and gameplay for each one you
know like video games needs to have
[Music]
Stark aside far cry 5 side missions are
real good and well worth your time from
simple missions like saving people from
drugged up bears to letting cows have
sex to Marvin Gaye music so you can chop
off their testicles for the annual test
FST
[Music]
that is in fact a real thing in this
game you can't wait to pop one of those
juicy balls into my mouth
you also get some pretty sweet rewards
like new weapons or beefed up vehicles
with guns on them every side mission
I've done has been worth the time
whether it's a sweet reward or just
something really funny happened so I
recommend doing them all
[Music]
expanding off the buddy system all the
way back in Far Cry 2 and the resistant
stuff in farcry 4 farcry 5 has he robust
cast of characters to call in and help
you out which you'll need because I
mentioned before the game can be pretty
tough there are 9 specialists you'll
find throughout Hope County and you'll
need to complete a story mission for
them all of their missions are marked on
the map from the get-go so it's pretty
easy to find them
each buddy has two abilities associated
with them for example boomer the dog can
tag all nearby enemies and fetch a
weapon for you after they attack making
him both a useful Scout and a very good
boy there's a great variety from Nick
the pilot to grace the sniper with the
leadership perk you can have access to
two at a time letting you combo
characters for the perfect attack they
also each have their own perk that
lessens the cooldown time for getting
them back so pick that up for your
favorites
just remember to dismiss Nick before you
try and stealth a outpost because he
will give away your position with a
carpet bomb
outside of the specialist there are
three slots you can fill with civilians
that you save and then higher they also
have two abilities but these need to be
unlocked by getting kills with them the
abilities are random though so if you
don't like them you can always get rid
of them and then hire a new person so I
hope these tricks and tips help you out
when playing far cry if it wasn't clear
from my enthusiasm I think far cry 5 is
Ubisoft's best open-world game in years
and I'm still finding cool stuff all the
time like did you know you can pet dogs
video games are good again go play far
cry
[Music]